let's go to our next caller we're taking
calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 we are gonna
go next to the 847 area code caller from
8 4 7 hope you can hear me tell us your
name where you're calling from and
what's on your mind today hi my name is
Steve I'm calling from Illinois awesome
what's going on my question is basically
about Trump Russia so so intelligence
experts and experts on the subject
almost universally agree that Putin is
attacking our democracy first line of
attack was to attack our political
system specifically the executive branch
those same intelligence experts are now
almost universally in agreement that
he'll attack again obviously I have to
be more covert about since the public's
aware of his intentions now I know that
you're not a counterintelligence expert
but what do you think the next line of
attack will be in 2018 or 2020 do you
think Putin will focus more on our media
and information systems or since he's
obviously decided to align himself with
the Republican Party for now do you
think he'll focus more on trying to
discredit liberal Congress people look
figures or intellectuals or will he go
after something completely different
that I'm not thinking of well your it's
not that your your thinking is wrong I
think you're thinking more at the micro
level whereas I believe that the success
that has been remember if you go back to
the GOP to foundations of geopolitics
this book from the 1990s by I forget the
author's name but I've mentioned
mentioned the book before it points to a
priority of basically destabilizing the
big Western democracies in particularly
the United States in order to learn
better the position of Russia
geopolitically so you're thinking at the
micro level like what about discrediting
congressmen or whoever this this that or
the other I think that the fact that
Donald Trump has been elected and has
been such an embarrassment on the
international stage that will allow
states like Russia to wreak havoc in
completely new ways that we're not even
considering a big picture right because
the fact that Trump will be President
more than likely when the midterms take
place in 2018 that in and of itself is a
systemic shift in the United States so I
don't know that we really can even guess
although I do believe that the cyber
warfare component should not be
understated right I have a quick
follow-up question okay sure
so as Muller concludes and announces
that Trump conspired with a foreign
dictatorship to cheat his way into
office essentially would any right wing
right wing nut jobs who persist in
trying to discredit Moeller and spread
information about the subject would they
essentially be guilty of treason if not
it's not in a legal sense of the word
than at least in a colloquial sense of
the word treason as in betraying our
country or democracy now they'd be
guilty of being idiots I think more than
anything else I don't know I mean that
guilty of treason in a colloquial sense
not really I mean it I think most of
them genuinely believe the nonsense that
they pair it so I think treason gives
them too much credit as having a clue
you know what I mean right right yeah
all right thanks for the call really
appreciate it okay thank you David all
right right here